hey what's up guys it's marcus brownlee
here from mkbhd and welcome to the
unboxing of the hp w1707
17-inch widescreen monitor so this is a
monitor that i actually saved up a
little bit to buy myself so this isn't
something that was sent to me by a
company to review so this is going to be
something that is something that i spent
a little bit of time researching in
order to buy and i really made the
investment in it so this is something
that i consider to be a quality product
before i even take it out of the box so
right at the top you can see there's a
little bit of styrofoam and we'll go
ahead and cut and have the styrofoam
open in a moment
so this is what it looks like once you
get it out of the box itself and
actually within the box next to the
styrofoam which is what made it so hard
to take out you get a couple of other
things besides the monitor you get the
ac power adapter to plug directly into
the back of the monitor
and you get your vga cable this does
come with a vga port a dvi port and the
power cable however this only comes with
the cable for hdmi so getting right into
the monitor itself it is pretty nicely
packaged as you can tell
it's face down the way i took it out of
the box
we also have this little aluminum or
some sort of brushed metal stand with
the uh rubber plating that will help it
uh keep from sliding it is a very
heavily weighted stand that will have to
attach to the monitor after we take it
out of the box
so now as we flip this over here i'll
just go right on ahead into the box and
open up the monitor
so this is what it's going to look like
out of the box guys very glossy really
nice finish and also a relatively thin
monitor now if we go ahead and turn it
around to the back you can see just
about those vents on the side of it and
also show you guys what it looks like
with everything else that came in the
box so you're definitely going to want
to attach that bottom stand thing to it
before you begin to use it
so uh let me go ahead and get that and
here you'll be able to just watch how
easy the installation is of the weighted
base
so now that we have it out of the box i
might as well give you guys a quick
hardware tour of the monitor and if you
guys will like i'll definitely give you
a review so the first thing on top is
the power button on the top right hand
side of the monitor
on the other side which is actually the
back side of the monitor if i can show
you guys the two connections here uh
pardon the quality the vga and the dvi
connections on the left hand side is
your power connection for the ac power
adapter that i showed you guys so if i
show you the front of the monitor there
on the right hand side are your
adjustments for your auto and your
volume which does have built-in speakers
in the monitor and a number of other
things so it does have a little bit of a
tilt which is helpful and the cool thing
is this laptop is actually going to be
our the monitor is going to be at the
same level as my laptop without any
adjustment needed so it's going to be
right on the same level as the cooler
that my laptop is on
so that has been the unboxing and the
quick hardware overview of the hp
w1707 17 inch
1440x900 monitor if you guys have any
questions about it just feel free to
drop a comment and until then i will
talk to you guys in the next video
thanks for watching peace